And he turned to us and was like, come in on Monday and you're hired.
他转向我们说，周一来，你就被录用了。
And we walked out and we're so stunned that we got lost in the complex L shape floor plan of the.
我们走出去，惊呆了，迷失在复杂的 L 形平面图中。
There's no way to get lost, but we all lost all the way down the hall.
没有办法迷路，但我们都迷路了。
We turned the only corner, we turned the corner, the only corner of the whole hallway.
我们拐过唯一的拐角，我们拐过拐角，整个走廊唯一的拐角。
And we turned the corner and like you can film this in your mind.
我们度过了难关，就像你可以在脑海中拍摄这一切一样。
It's it's high noon.
正是正午时分。
And there are the other end is David Letterman, like standing alone, like I think he was like tossing a football, just standing there, like he's maybe going to kick our ass or something.
另一端是大卫·莱特曼（David Letterman），他就像一个人站着，我觉得他就像在扔一个足球，站在那里，好像他可能会踢我们的屁股什么的。
And we say to him, do you know where the elevator is?
我们对他说，你知道电梯在哪里吗？
It's Josh, right?
是乔什，对吧？
And we're welcome to a bonus episode of how we made your mother.
欢迎收看关于我们如何造就你母亲的额外剧集。
We heard the tale of how Craig and Carter came to write, how I met your mother.
我们听到了克雷格和卡特如何开始写作的故事，以及我如何遇见你母亲的故事。
But there's an even deeper, richer backstory, how Craig met Carter and we're going to get into this twisty, windy mystery right now.
但还有一个更深刻、更丰富的背景故事，克雷格如何遇见卡特，我们现在将进入这个曲折、多风的谜团。
I want to get first the origin story of how you two met Carter and Craig or Craig and Carter.
我想先了解你们两个如何认识卡特和克雷格或克雷格和卡特的起源故事。
It's really Carter and Craig.
确实是卡特和克雷格。
Tell us how you guys met and what were your first impressions of each other.
告诉我们你们是如何认识的以及你们对彼此的第一印象是什么。
I'm just curious.
我只是好奇。
if you remember the moment you met each other?
你还记得你们相遇的那一刻吗？
I don't remember, I don't remember this meeting.
我不记得了，我不记得这次会议。
I, we were sort of both part of the, part of the furniture at Wesleyan for, for a good year and a half, I think before we actually like had a conversation.
我，我们都是卫斯理学院家具的一部分，整整一年半的时间，我想在我们真正喜欢进行一次对话之前。
I remember Craig played drums.
我记得克雷格打鼓。
That made him a very like, very in demand commodity in the, in the music world.
这使他成为音乐界非常受欢迎、非常抢手的商品。
I, I was like a singer and guitarist and not very good at either.
我，我就像一个歌手和吉他手，但两者都不太擅长。
So like I wanted to be in a band really bad and no one was taking and Craig was in like seven bands, He had a prom set and he could play and he was really good.
所以就像我非常想加入一支乐队，但没有人接受，而克雷格参加了大约七个乐队，他有一个舞会演出，他可以演奏，而且他真的很棒。
And yeah, we sort of like English classes.
是的，我们有点喜欢英语课。
I think we were in some English store story writing classes and some like screenwriting classes and just sort of eyeballed each other from across the conference table.
我想我们参加了一些英语商店故事写作课程，还有一些类似的编剧课程，我们只是在会议桌对面互相注视着对方。
I'm going to create a hit TV show with that guy one day.
有一天我要和那个人一起制作一部热门电视节目。
I just had a few.
我只吃了一些。
Yeah, first of all, Carter's underselling his singing prowess.
是的，首先，卡特低估了他的歌唱实力。
He was an intimate, like once you actually got on there and sang everyone was like, wait a second, let's get that, like then you would then the table's turned.
他是一个亲密的人，就像一旦你真正登上那里并唱歌，每个人都会说，等一下，让我们开始吧，就像然后你就会扭转局面一样。
No one gave a shit about the drummer anymore.
没有人再关心鼓手了。
So I just want to make that very clear.
所以我只想说得非常清楚。
I tried.
我试过。
I, someone heard me hollering in the showers and that was it.
我，有人听到我在淋浴时大喊大叫，就是这样。
Was there a moment when you guys made each other laugh for you, you, you started thinking comedically?
有没有那么一瞬间，你们让彼此为你而笑，你，你开始用喜剧的方式思考？
I remember we were in a screenwriting class together.
我记得我们一起上编剧课。
I feel like before we were really friends, what really made us friends is playing in a band together.
我觉得在我们成为真正的朋友之前，真正让我们成为朋友的是一起在乐队里演奏。
We finally got in a band together a junior year, right?
我们终于在大三的时候组建了一个乐队，对吧？
Carter and then we're in bands together the whole second half of college and to this day, we still play in a band together.
卡特和我们整个大学后半段都在乐队里，直到今天，我们仍然一起在乐队里演奏。
That was very much our first way we worked together was playing in a band but we weren't like close because Carter was the lead singer.
这很大程度上是我们合作的第一个方式是在乐队中演奏，但我们的关系并不亲密，因为卡特是主唱。
We were in a nine piece soul band with like four horns and I was behind a drum set.
我们在一个九人灵魂乐队中，有四个号角，我在鼓组后面。
In the band we barely had a conversation.
在乐队里我们几乎没有交谈。
It was really true.
这确实是真的。
Like seven is like, I feel like that's that's conservative.
就像七一样，我觉得那是保守的。
I think we got upwards of like 12.
我想我们大概有 12 个以上。
It was like the size of like a, like an early 2000s.
它的大小就像 2000 年代初期一样。
The polyphonic spree.
复调狂欢。
It was a full, full choir.
这是一个完整的合唱团。
Yeah, I think we had like two rows of risers, but you know, it was, it was a lot of people.
是的，我想我们有两排立管，但你知道，有很多人。
So we didn't really, yeah, we didn't, it was like the real moment I feel like was MTV.
所以我们真的没有，是的，我们没有，这就像我觉得 MTV 的真实时刻。
We, we, Craig and I got a, that we played in this band together all June your year.
我们，我们，克雷格和我，我们整个六月都在这个乐队里一起演奏。
And then I feel like the way I retell this story, and maybe this is true, or maybe this is apocryphal, but I feel like maybe we didn't know each, didn't know that the other was applying to this internship, but then we showed up in New York City.
然后我觉得我重述这个故事的方式，也许这是真的，或者也许这是杜撰的，但我觉得也许我们并不认识，不知道对方正在申请这份实习，但后来我们出现在纽约市。
Like we went in for like on a weekday, and in some time in the spring of, I guess it would be 1996, to both to interview for an internship at MTV to in their development department, which we didn't, I don't think we even knew what development meant.
就像我们在一个工作日，在春天的某个时候，我想那是 1996 年，两人都去 MTV 面试他们的开发部门的实习机会，但我们没有，我想我们甚至不知道开发意味着什么。
I thought, like, are we, like, hanging photographs on paper or on the screen?
我想，我们是把照片挂在纸上还是屏幕上？
Plus, there's never going to be an era where MTV does anything but play music videos.
另外，永远不会有 MTV 除了播放音乐视频之外什么都不做的时代。
So what kind of shows are they going to play?
那么他们会表演什么样的节目呢？
So wait, so this was between your junior and senior year?
那么等等，这是你大三和大四之间的事情吗？
That's it.
就是这样。
Yes.
是的。
So then, I know that you guys, by the time you graduated, is it true you had, like, a comedy packet together, just the two of you?
那么，我知道你们，当你们毕业的时候，你们真的有一个喜剧包吗？只有你们两个人在一起吗？
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Yeah.
是的。
We started writing it.
我们开始写它。
that summer working at MTV.
那年夏天在 MTV 工作。
And again, that was after a year of being in a band at some point during which Carter was like, I think there's a drummer back there behind some of those horn players.
再说一次，那是在乐队呆了一年之后的某个时候，卡特就像是，我认为在一些喇叭手后面有一个鼓手。
And I was like, I said, I'm like, I'm not sure.
我说，我想，我不确定。
He looks like the guy that sings the songs.
他看起来就像那个唱歌的人。
We were just like, we weren't close in the band because the band was 45 people.
我们当时就想，我们在乐队中的关系并不亲密，因为乐队有 45 人。
But we then, we really bonded at MTV, but we'd also already had a screenwriting class and I'll embarrass Carter again by saying, first of all, he was a great singer and he was very in demand to be a singer.
但后来我们在 MTV 上真正建立了联系，但我们也已经上了编剧课，我会再次让卡特感到尴尬，首先，他是一位伟大的歌手，而且非常需要他成为一名歌手。
And second, he was in a screenwriting class with me.
其次，他和我一起上编剧课。
And he was the best fucking writer.
他是最棒的作家。
He was, well, I wanted you.
他是，好吧，我想要你。
I wanted you, but you Carter was like his writing so stood out in the screenwriting class.
我想要你，但你卡特就像他的作品一样在编剧班上脱颖而出。
It was just like a dinky little, right?
它就像一个很小的小东西，对吧？
Like 10 or 12 people, we sort of volunteered scenes and you were like the only person cobbling together, using it to cobble together a feature length script.
就像 10 或 12 个人一样，我们有点自愿制作场景，而你就像是唯一一个拼凑在一起的人，用它拼凑出一个长篇剧本。
And I just remember going like the balls on this fucking guy.
我只记得我对这个该死的家伙很感兴趣。
Oh, right.
哦，对了。
But with admiration, I was like, this guy, right?
但带着钦佩之情，我想，这家伙，对吗？
You were putting, I remember when the script was, I remember it was good.
你在写，我记得剧本当时写的，我记得那很好。
It was insane and funny and violent.
这是疯狂、有趣和暴力的。
It was like, it was like, it was like, it was like, it was like, it was like, it was like, it was like, Heather is ish.
就像，就像，就像，就像，就像，就像，就像，希瑟是这样。
I feel like you told me that there was a lot of buzz about Carter before he even got to school because he had a play being produced off Broadway and he was late for school.
我感觉你告诉我卡特在上学之前就已经有很多关于他的传闻了，因为他在百老汇正在制作一部戏剧，而他上学迟到了。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
That is true.
确实如此。
Yes.
是的。
I had a play that I wrote.
我有一个自己写的剧本。
I was really into playwriting in high school, just fell in love with theater and I wrote a few short plays and on a whim, just sent one of them into the New York Young Playwrights Festival, which was like a big contest.
我在高中时非常喜欢剧本创作，只是爱上了戏剧，我写了一些短剧，一时兴起，就把其中的一部送到了纽约青年剧作家节，这就像一场大型比赛。
At the time, it was a, it was a, it was a, I mean, this is before YouTube, it was back when like, there was no like, you know, you had to like physically print something out and send it out to New York for any chance of anyone ever seeing it, you know.
当时，这是，这是，这是，我的意思是，这是在 YouTube 之前，当时还没有类似的东西，你知道，你必须打印一些东西并将其发送到纽约，以便任何人有机会看到它，你知道。
So it was, I just sent this thing in and it ended up winning and the prize was a two months production of my show as part of a night of one acts at young playwrights horizons theater in New York, which I later found out, like, oh, that's actually a really good theater.
事情就是这样，我刚刚把这个东西寄了进去，它最终获胜了，奖品是我的节目为期两个月的制作，作为纽约年轻剧作家地平线剧院的一个表演之夜的一部分，我后来发现，哦，那实际上是一个非常好的剧院。
It's kind of, it was a big deal.
有点，这是一件大事。
And it was, the play was directed by Michael Mayer.
确实，该剧由迈克尔·梅尔执导。
Yeah.
是的。
I always find this amazing at what age did you say I want to, I want to write things.
我总是觉得这很神奇，你说我想在什么年纪，我想写东西。
I want to write plays.
我想写戏剧。
I want to write movies.
我想写电影。
I think it was like, I, I'm going to say I was 14.
我想这就像，我，我会说我14岁。
I was really into, into watching stuff, like I just was a voracious consumer of television and movies and you know it was the golden age of video stores and so I had a bunch of friends who were really into like zombie movies and stuff and like I, but then it was actually, I took a trip to the library, the public library which my first time got out.
我真的很喜欢看东西，就像我是电视和电影的贪婪消费者一样，你知道这是音像店的黄金时代，所以我有一群朋友非常喜欢僵尸电影和东西，就像我一样，但事实上，我去了图书馆，我第一次出去的公共图书馆。
I found there was a book called How to Write a a movie in 21 days by, I think it was Vicki King was maybe the name.
我发现有一本书叫《如何在 21 天里写一部电影》，我想这可能是 Vicki King 的名字。
I can't remember the person who wrote it, but it's the book that changed my life.
我不记得是谁写的，但这本书改变了我的生活。
I was like a little slim, a little volume stuck between their film section of the Shaker Heights public library, but I was like, oh, write a film.
我就像一个瘦小的小卷，卡在谢克高地公共图书馆的电影区之间，但我想，哦，写一部电影。
You can do that.
你可以这么做。
I guess films get written.
我猜电影是写出来的。
Someone has to write down on paper what the actors are going to say, and that just kicked the door down.
必须有人把演员要说的话写在纸上，这就把门踢开了。
And after that, I'm going to write screenplays.
之后，我会写剧本。
Do you ever find it astonishing, like, I always think a 15 year old teenager decided what I was going to do for my life?
你有没有觉得很惊讶，比如，我总是认为一个 15 岁的青少年决定了我一生要做什么？
Just like how astonishing that is, like a 14 year old boy said you're going to be a writer.
就像一个 14 岁的男孩说你要成为一名作家一样，这是多么令人惊讶。
I feel like, do you know the show Passing Strange by Stu?
我觉得，你知道 Stu 的《Passing Strange》这部剧吗？
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
He has a line like that.
他有这样的台词。
It's kind of the same thing.
这是一样的事情。
Yeah, it's like this ding dong, who doesn't know anything about anything is, but having some sort of like the life visionary, almost prophetic sense of like, this this would be a good idea.
是的，就像这个叮咚，什么都不知道，但是有某种像生活的远见，几乎是预言般的感觉，这将是一个好主意。
We should do this impossible thing.
我们应该做这件不可能的事。
Yeah.
是的。
And it was absolutely right in all of our cases.
在我们所有的案例中，这都是绝对正确的。
That is what we were supposed to be doing.
这就是我们应该做的。
You know, it's funny about reminiscing about college because Alec Lavar, producer extraordinaire went to Wesleyan with us, me and Carter.
你知道，回忆大学时光很有趣，因为出色的制片人亚历克·拉瓦尔 (Alec Lavar) 和我们、我和卡特一起去了卫斯理学院。
And I often feel like Josh went to Wesleyan because he played a guy who went to Wesleyan on how I met your mother.
我经常觉得乔什去了卫斯理安，因为他在我如何认识你母亲的过程中扮演了一个去了卫斯理安的人。
I mean, forget that you did Rex.
我的意思是，忘记你做了雷克斯。
We still don't know.
我们仍然不知道。
He, yeah, he was just disguised as Dr. X.
他，是的，他只是伪装成X博士。
That's why we didn't know.
这就是为什么我们不知道。
Well, a lot of Wesleyan grads think I went to Wesleyan.
嗯，很多卫斯理学院的毕业生都认为我去了卫斯理学院。
It really feels like, even to me, it feels I'd like to steal petition for my honorary degree.
即使对我来说，我真的感觉我想窃取我的荣誉学位的请愿书。
You should only get one.
你应该只得到一个。
Yeah.
是的。
It feels like it's New Yorker who went to Wesleyan.
感觉就像是纽约客去了卫斯理安。
It very much feels that way.
非常有这种感觉。
It's what I would have been like Carter and Ohio and who went to Wesleyan.
这就是我会像卡特和俄亥俄州一样，他们去了卫斯理安。
Exactly.
确切地。
Yeah.
是的。
So hiring and sort of wearing the costume of a New Yorker.
所以雇用并穿着纽约人的服装。
Yeah, that's right.
是的，没错。
That's right.
这是正确的。
Yeah.
是的。
Did you read the post today?
今天的帖子你读了吗？
Steinbrunner.
斯坦布伦纳。
In New York City Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the HyperFixed podcast.
在纽约 大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，HyperFixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the HyperFixed podcast from Radio Topia.
这是来自 Radio Topia 的 HyperFixed 播客。
find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 HyperFixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
So you have this internship.
所以你有这个实习机会。
You guys connect comedically.
你们之间的联系很喜剧。
You're whole senior year.
你已经高三了。
Did you, did you start writing comedy together?
你们开始一起写喜剧了吗？
Yeah, that was where we dove in.
是的，这就是我们投入的地方。
Like it was, I think we were both sort of looking down the barrel of like, you know, what are we going to do after we graduate?
就像以前一样，我想我们都在低头思考，你知道，我们毕业后要做什么？
And this is in the golden age of like, like Anderson consulting, like everyone was going into consulting firms.
这是安德森咨询公司的黄金时代，每个人都进入咨询公司。
Like there's all these consulting firms.
就像所有这些咨询公司一样。
And it was sort of like, is that, I guess it was sort of like the job for like if you have a bachelor's degree and you have no idea what you're going to do, just go into consulting.
这有点像，我想这有点像这样的工作，如果你有学士学位，但你不知道自己要做什么，就去做咨询。
Yeah.
是的。
And other than that it was like I had no idea and then Craig and I went to did this internship at MTV and saw how TV is made and realized like oh we love writing and here's a job because I and I psychoanalyzed myself about this a lot.
除此之外，我好像不知道，然后克雷格和我去 MTV 实习，看到电视是如何制作的，并意识到我们喜欢写作，这是一份工作，因为我和我对自己进行了很多心理分析。
My dad was a lawyer and he grew up sort of putting on a suit every day and going to work with his briefcase and coming home And I never, no one ever modeled the Bohemian life for me.
我父亲是一名律师，他从小到大每天都会穿上西装，提着公文包去上班，然后回家，而我从来没有人为我塑造过波西米亚生活。
Lovey Bohem, you know, no sense of like, oh, this is how to be an artist.
Lovey Bohem，你知道，没有感觉，哦，这就是成为一名艺术家的方式。
This is like how to, so in my mind, it was like, I want to be an artist.
这就像如何，所以在我看来，就像，我想成为一名艺术家。
But like, when I'm a grown-up, I'm going to have to have a job with an office, with a desk that I sit at where I do my job and then come home.
但就像，当我长大了，我必须找到一份有办公室的工作，有一张办公桌，我坐在办公桌上工作，然后回家。
Like, and there's no.
喜欢，而且没有。
Come home exhausted and depleted.
回到家已经精疲力尽、疲惫不堪。
Yeah, come home exhausted and depleted and quietly stare into the fire, drinking and Jen, which my dad did not do.
是的，疲惫不堪地回到家，静静地盯着火，喝酒和珍，而我爸爸没有这样做。
That was just me.
那只是我。
That's kind of what I'm crying right now, personally.
就我个人而言，这就是我现在哭泣的原因。
No, but seeing TV, it was like, oh, here's a thing where you're writing, but all the things that are bad about writing, like the uncertainty of where you're going to do it, well, that's taken care of because you have an office and the loneliness of writing is just sitting in a room doing that.
不，但是看电视，就好像，哦，这是你正在写作的东西，但是写作的所有不好的事情，比如你要在哪里做的不确定性，好吧，这都得到了照顾，因为你有一个办公室，而写作的孤独感只是坐在一个房间里这样做。
And like, you find out like, oh, TV shows are written by like a bunch of idiots sitting around a table, just like I sit around a table at a diner with my friends, just goofing around.
就像，你发现，哦，电视节目是由一群白痴围坐在桌子旁写的，就像我和朋友围坐在餐馆的桌子旁，只是闲逛一样。
That's how TV is made, I mean, and I think Craig felt the same way and we were sort of like, all right, this is, if nothing else, like this is one thing that we can do, you know, after June 1997 that I've never thought about it exactly this way, just, but just because of exactly how you just said that Carter, I did see love Vibo M in a way, because my dad was an advertising copywriter, like a madman-era advertising copywriter.
我的意思是，电视就是这样制作的，我想克雷格也有同样的感觉，我们有点像，好吧，如果没有别的，这是我们可以做的一件事，你知道，在 1997 年 6 月之后，我从来没有这样想过，只是，但正是因为你刚才说卡特，我确实在某种程度上看到了爱 Vibo M，因为我的父亲是一名广告文案，就像一个疯子时代的广告文案。
And the funny thing is, I watched him come home at night, be so stressed out by writing deadlines that he chained smoke and drank vodka tonics and was kind of miserable a great deal of time.
有趣的是，我看到他晚上回家，因为写最后期限而感到压力很大，以至于他抽烟、喝伏特加补品，很长一段时间都很痛苦。
And I went, I want to do that.
我去了，我想这么做。
That is the key to longevity and happiness.
这是长寿和幸福的关键。
I'm going down that path.
我正沿着那条路走下去。
So I had a little hint that people wrote things and got paid for it.
所以我有一点暗示，人们写东西并为此获得报酬。
So I had a little head start on knowing that was a thing although it was ads, it was commercials and print ads and stuff.
所以我先一步知道这是一件事，尽管它是广告、商业广告和平面广告之类的东西。
I was really into it, but I, but yeah, I'm the guy who like watched Barton Fink, which is essentially a study like in hell via through the, you know, it was through the lens of writer, like being literally in development.
我真的很喜欢它，但是我，但是，是的，我是那个喜欢看《巴顿·芬克》的人，这本质上是一项像地狱一样的研究，通过，你知道，这是通过作家的镜头，就像字面意义上的发展一样。
Hell and I went, that seems fun.
地狱和我去了，这看起来很有趣。
I just have like the punishment of it.
我只是喜欢它的惩罚。
I want it or something, but I think the thing, the thing that sparked for me when you were saying that Surrey Carter is you made it, I think the part I was scared about was the loneliness because it was my dad alone in a room really doing everything kind of for his agency.
我想要它或其他东西，但我认为，当你说萨里·卡特是你做到了的时候，这件事给我带来了火花，我认为我害怕的部分是孤独，因为我父亲独自一人在一个房间里，真正为他的机构做着一切。
It was like the creative doctor.
这就像一位富有创造力的医生。
He was like the soul showrunner.
他就像灵魂剧的制作人。
And getting to make stuff up with you, like, really having a partner really helped me so much, I think, because I was scared of that part of it, the kind of loneliness and having my dad just seemed lonely in their writing every night.
和你和好，就像，真正有一个伴侣真的对我帮助很大，我想，因为我害怕其中的那一部分，那种孤独，有我父亲在每晚的写作中显得孤独。
And he was really good at it, but I, and there are ways in which writing even in a partnership, we would divvy up our tasks, you and I, we would each go right and you wanted that time.
他真的很擅长，但我，还有很多方法，即使是在合作伙伴关系中写作，我们也会分配我们的任务，你和我，我们每个人都会做对，而你想要那个时间。
But having a partner to figure it out with at the beginning meant everything to me.
但一开始就有一个合作伙伴来解决这个问题对我来说意味着一切。
And I think got me over the fear of, like, the part that seemed scariest for my dad, which was being alone.
我认为这让我克服了对我父亲来说最可怕的恐惧，那就是孤独。
And in a kind of meta way, I mean, you guys ended up creating a show that was about people finding community and a hedge against loneliness, you know, going through the tough times together.
我的意思是，以某种元的方式，你们最终创作了一部关于人们寻找社区和对抗孤独的节目，你知道，一起度过艰难时期。
I have to say, Carter, when you described, you know, your dad and the suit and the lawyer, maybe it's an Ohio thing, not that everyone in Ohio is a lawyer, but it was the exact same thing.
我不得不说，卡特，当你描述你的父亲、诉讼和律师时，也许这是俄亥俄州的事情，并不是俄亥俄州的每个人都是律师，但这是完全相同的事情。
I thought, I just don't want to wear a tie to my job.
我想，我只是不想在工作中打领带。
If I can just create a job where I don't have to wear a tie.
如果我能创造一份不需要打领带的工作就好了。
I like ties, special occasions, but I don't want to wear one every day.
我喜欢领带，喜欢特殊场合，但我不想每天都戴。
So when I discovered the theater and I saw adults, you know, that made plays for a living, and I just thought, get me in there.
因此，当我发现剧院并看到以戏剧为生的成年人时，我就想，让我进去吧。
Yeah.
是的。
It's funny to say ties, because I feel like there's so much of that in like, especially like, okay, so like Barney, we're jumping all over the place here, but like Barney's obsession with suits.
说领带很有趣，因为我觉得有很多这样的东西，特别是，好吧，就像巴尼一样，我们在这里到处跳，但就像巴尼对西装的痴迷一样。
I absolutely feel like that comes from some some deep dark place that we probably all connect with generation.
我绝对觉得这来自于我们可能都与这一代人联系在一起的某个深处的黑暗地方。
My dad is going out putting on suits.
我爸爸要出去穿西装。
You know, the huge movie for me was The Commitment, which was like, you know, the movie about the, the Dublin Soul Band, the guys that sort of soul band in Dublin.
你知道，对我来说最重要的电影是《承诺》，这就像一部关于都柏林灵魂乐队的电影，那些在都柏林的灵魂乐队。
And Craig and I started a soul band in, in, in, in, uh, the middle tech, which is probably somewhat inspired by that.
克雷格和我在中间技术中创立了一个灵魂乐队，这可能在某种程度上受到了启发。
And part of the whole thing was, uh, you know, they wear suits.
整个事情的一部分是，呃，你知道，他们穿西装。
And like, they have a whole discussion in the movie about like, oh, you got to put on a suit because suit makes you play better.
就像，他们在电影中进行了一次完整的讨论，比如，哦，你必须穿上西装，因为西装让你打得更好。
You play better in your suit.
穿上你的套装你会打得更好。
And like, the idea of a suit as something you wear recreationally, as something you put on because you want to.
就像，西装是你休闲时穿的东西，是你因为想要穿而穿的东西。
That was the, I think that was the key to Barney.
我认为这就是巴尼的关键。
It was like, he's not like, you know, because he was like, I saw my, my dad, you know, he retired and was like, I'm never putting on a suit again.
就像，他不像，你知道，因为他就像，我看到了我的，我的父亲，你知道，他退休了，然后就像，我再也不会穿西装了。
And like, I don't They have seen my Godness.
就像，我不知道他们见过我的上帝。
This is really, really tired of you since then.
从那时起，你就真的真的厌倦了。
Yeah.
是的。
So like the, it's sort of like the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the spirit of like, I'm seizing control of this.
所以就像，有点像，这个，这个，这个，这个，这个，这个，这个，这个，类似的精神，我正在控制这个。
I'm, I'm, I'm wearing this suit by choice.
我，我，我穿这套衣服是我自己选择的。
I think that that's so interesting.
我认为这很有趣。
There is a connection between us putting on those suits in the soul band in Wesleyan when we were 19 and 20 and Barney.
当我们 19 岁和 20 岁的时候，我们在卫斯理安灵魂乐队中穿上这些套装和巴尼之间存在着某种联系。
There's a literal, there's a straight line between the idea of choosing your own suit destiny.
从字面上看，选择自己的西装命运的想法之间有一条直线。
Yeah.
是的。
And there was absolutely a sort of, we did sort of the experimental anthropology of seeing what it's like to walk around in a suit, especially on a college campus, especially campus like Wesleyan, that's like, you know, just a bunch of hippies and stuff, but like walking around in a suit, like you, you do realize like, oh, I'm radiating this weird power that I think I have, I'm making each one of these kids think of their dad.
我们做了某种实验人类学，看看穿着西装走来走去是什么感觉，特别是在大学校园，尤其是像卫斯理安这样的校园，就像，你知道，只是一群嬉皮士之类的东西，但就像穿着西装走来走去，像你一样，你确实意识到，哦，我正在散发着我认为我拥有的这种奇怪的力量，我让这些孩子中的每一个都想起了他们的父亲。
They're all thinking that their dad who disappointed that they didn't get into Harvard.
他们都认为他们的父亲对他们没有进入哈佛感到失望。
And what are you studying?
你在学什么？
studies, why are you crying again?
学习了，你怎么又哭了？
Yeah, there was, there was a power in wearing the suit.
是的，穿着这套衣服有一种力量。
It's kind of like how Barney ended up in the suit.
这有点像巴尼最终穿上诉讼的样子。
Oh, man, that's great.
哦，伙计，那太好了。
Paul Feig says it, they'll let you in anywhere if you're carrying a clipboard.
保罗·费格说过，只要你带着写字板，他们就会让你进入任何地方。
Like you can only do any building in the world.
就像你只能建造世界上任何建筑一样。
Yeah, too.
是的，也是。
But if you have a laminated thing, a laminated necklace, you can walk right into the oval office.
但如果你有层压制品，比如层压项链，你就可以直接走进椭圆形办公室。
It's also just funny where you're like, I'm not wearing this unless it's semi-ironic.
这也很有趣，你会说，我不会穿这个，除非它是半讽刺的。
Like I have to be in control of when and then how I'm putting on this.
就像我必须控制何时以及如何穿上它。
And to be clear, our suits in that band were like from the ladies auxiliary theft store and middle band Connecticut.
需要明确的是，我们那个乐队的套装就像来自康涅狄格州的女士辅助盗窃店和中乐队。
And my, my mind was red, except the red blazer didn't quite match the red pants.
我的心是红色的，除了红色西装外套与红色裤子不太匹配。
Look at it.
看看它。
It's two different rads.
这是两个不同的拉德。
Like Barney would have been like, what in the world?
就像巴尼会想的那样，这到底是怎么回事？
So we gave away two red suits.
所以我们赠送了两套红色套装。
Yeah.
是的。
Two red suits.
两套红色西装。
They were somewhat similar and I was like, sold.
它们有点相似，我就想，被卖掉了。
I've got three dollars and I'm looking to spend it.
我有三美元，我想花掉它。
Okay.
好的。
So you guys, you're senior year, you, you create enough comedy that you have this comedy packet enough to write, send it out to agents and staffing.
所以你们，你们已经是大四了，你们创造了足够多的喜剧，你们有足够的喜剧包来写，把它发送给经纪人和工作人员。
This is a good chance to give a shout out to somebody who, so, you remember those people and you've had them too, Josh, where the person that kind of changed your life, right, Carter, this executive in MTV, we were there getting him coffee and getting sushi and making photo copies and we were writing our little comedy ideas.
这是一个向某人大声喊叫的好机会，所以，你记得那些人，你也遇到过他们，乔什，那个改变了你生活的人，对吧，卡特，MTV 的这位高管，我们在那里给他喝咖啡，买寿司，复印照片，我们正在写我们的喜剧小创意。
We were just like, we had been in a band and we started writing comedy together because we clicked so much.
我们就像是，我们一直在一个乐队里，我们开始一起写喜剧，因为我们太合拍了。
We started writing our own ideas and submitting it to this executive.
我们开始写下自己的想法并将其提交给这位高管。
this guy, Jeremiah Boschang, who had been executive at NBC, he had worked on Seinfeld and now he's in MTV and he saw our little ideas and thought there were clever and interesting enough that he submitted, he, I think, submitted them for us Carter and maybe gave us permission to connect it.
这个人，Jeremiah Boschang，曾是 NBC 的执行官，他曾在《Seinfeld》工作过，现在他在 MTV，他看到了我们的小想法，并认为这些想法足够聪明和有趣，所以他提交了，我认为，他为我们提交了这些想法，卡特，也许还允许我们将其连接起来。
No, he gave us the, the, the, it was, I mean, this is how, I, like, people, I'm, I'm sure people ask you, like, how, how do you get your start?
不，他给了我们，那个，那个，它是，我的意思是，这就是我，喜欢，人们，我，我确信人们会问你，比如，你如何开始？
And it's like, our start is so not connected with anything in 2025.
就好像，我们的开始与 2025 年的任何事情都没有关系。
Like it's sort of like old school.
就像它有点像老学校。
He literally was like send a packet of material with a cover letter that you print out and put in the mail.
他实际上就像发送一包带有求职信的材料，您将其打印出来并放入邮件中。
And in the cover letter, mention my name in the first sentence.
在求职信中，在第一句话中提到我的名字。
And that was like all the, like that was the little like just tights, gauss number thin filament of like connection to like if he doesn't read that first sentence then it goes on some, it goes in the fire and then that's it.
这就像所有的，就像那只是紧身衣，高斯数细丝的连接，就像如果他不读第一句话，那么它就会继续下去，它会进入火中，然后就是这样。
It wasn't really email, right?
这不是真正的电子邮件，对吧？
There was like, yeah, there was, we were still in the era where you went to the Science Center in college to send an email.
就像，是的，我们仍然处于大学科学中心发送电子邮件的时代。
I've gotta go to the Science Center to send out this message.
我得去科学中心发出这个消息。
I've been trying to do snow.
我一直在尝试做雪。
We found a thousand years old in this entire, the theme of this whole episode is we're so fucking old.
我们发现这整集已经有一千年了，整集的主题是我们他妈的老了。
That's the theme of this entire thing so far.
这就是到目前为止整件事的主题。
But somehow that worked out and by that guy believing in us, it got to an agent, an agency, who was one of the partners there.
但不知怎的，事情成功了，通过那个相信我们的人，它到达了一个代理人，一个机构，他是那里的合作伙伴之一。
This guy, Elliot Webb, was Broder, Kirland Webb, I think.
我认为这个人，埃利奥特·韦伯，就是布罗德，科兰·韦伯。
And he was like, I'm a partner, I'm too big for this thing, but they seem clever and they seem, I like this guy Jeremiah.
他说，我是一个合伙人，我对这件事来说太大了，但他们看起来很聪明，而且他们似乎，我喜欢耶利米这个人。
So he gave it to literally the guy who became our agent and his agent to this day, Matt Rice.
所以他把它交给了后来成为我们经纪人的人，也是他至今的经纪人，马特·赖斯。
So again, our story is useless to anyone because number one, it sounds ancient and also number two, it's, it's impossible.
再说一次，我们的故事对任何人都没用，因为第一，它听起来很古老，第二，它是不可能的。
That should not have worked.
那不应该起作用。
We sent out one thing.
我们发出了一件事。
The guy actually gave it to a junior agent who became roasted to ranks.
这家伙实际上把它给了一个初级特工，后者被炒了。
Matt Rice is like a big powerful agent and well deserved with these.
马特·赖斯就像一个强大的特工，当之无愧。
So he's amazing.
所以他很了不起。
Yeah, he just started.
是的，他才刚刚开始。
He just started.
他才刚刚开始。
at this point, yeah, I think.
在这一点上，是的，我想。
Yeah, he was like five.
是的，他大概五岁。
Was he, were you guys like kind of his first clients?
他，你们是他的第一个客户吗？
No, but you know who was?
不，但你知道是谁吗？
Will Forte and Chris Miller and Phil Lord were among his first clients.
威尔·福特、克里斯·米勒和菲尔·洛德是他的第一批客户。
They was like, we were a few in past them.
他们就像是，我们比他们早了一些。
So that's how good this guy is.
所以说这个人的素质就这么好。
And like being a good agent really, there really is a like instinctual super power, spidey sense thing that happens when he has it.
就像真正成为一名优秀的特工一样，当他拥有这种能力时，确实会发生一种本能的超能力，蜘蛛侠般的感觉。
And we were, so we were in a great company right away and Matt Rice helped us get to who's our manager at the time, David Minor.
我们是这样的，所以我们马上就加入了一家伟大的公司，马特·赖斯（Matt Rice）帮助我们找到了当时的经理大卫·米诺（David Minor）。
all kind of toward the end and coming out of college.
一切都快要结束了，大学毕业了。
And that's somehow led to us getting our Letterman material.
这在某种程度上导致我们获得了莱特曼的材料。
We'd written some Conan in material, we'd written a sign fell, we'd written SNL ideas, but Letterman was hiring.
我们写了一些《柯南》的材料，我们写了一个标志坠落，我们写了《周六夜现场》的想法，但莱特曼正在招聘。
Like Conan was like, we were obsessed with our dream with Conan.
就像柯南一样，我们痴迷于与柯南的梦想。
That was the biggest part of it also was like, we want to live in New York.
这是其中最重要的部分，我们想住在纽约。
Neither of us had any interest in going to LA.
我们俩都没有兴趣去洛杉矶。
And so that really at the time, it was SNL, Conan, Letterman, Daily Show.
所以当时确实是《周六夜现场》、《柯南》、《莱特曼》和《每日秀》。
show, the Daily Show, I think maybe the Craig Killborne Daily Show may have existed.
节目，每日秀，我想也许克雷格基尔伯恩每日秀可能已经存在。
But I don't think we were, we were, yeah, we weren't trying that.
但我不认为我们是，我们是，是的，我们没有尝试这样做。
But yeah.
但是是的。
But it was like there's four jobs for comedy writers in, in New York in, in 1997.
但 1997 年的纽约，喜剧作家似乎有四份工作。
And we were obsessed with Conan.
我们对柯南很着迷。
It was like the year of like, where like Robert Smigel was running it.
那就像罗伯特·斯密格尔（Robert Smigel）主持的那一年。
And it was just like going bananas.
这就像发疯一样。
And just like every, like, it was, it was definitely like, if I, if I'm gonna do anything for living.
就像每个人一样，如果我要为生活做任何事，那绝对是这样。
I want to, I want to write this dumb stuff.
我想，我想写这些愚蠢的东西。
It was definitely the weirdest thing happening on TV.
这绝对是电视上发生的最奇怪的事情。
It was.
是的。
It was like very strange.
感觉很奇怪。
Like, yeah.
就像，是的。
Can I just push back on, on, on, on your, on your path to success a little bit as a thing that isn't repeatable?
我可以在你的成功之路上稍微推一下，推一下，推一下，推一下，作为一件不可重复的事情吗？
Another way I, I think I'll look at it.
我想我会以另一种方式看待它。
Greg is Letterman's nephew.
格雷格是莱特曼的侄子。
Okay.
好的。
Isn't exactly the way that you make it.
不完全是你做的方式。
You do the best that you can up until this one magical line, and you have to do the absolute best you can be incredibly talented, put in a huge amount of work, and that's all you can do.
在这一条神奇的路线之前，你会尽你所能，你必须尽你最大的努力，你可以拥有令人难以置信的天赋，投入大量的工作，这就是你所能做的。
And then on the other side of the line is a whole series of luck, always, but that luck is because you've you've walked up to the door with the right materials and the right person open it.
然后，在这条线的另一边，总是有一系列的运气，但这种运气是因为你已经带着正确的材料走到了门口，并且正确的人打开了它。
That's exactly the way it works, but we did work really hard.
这就是它的运作方式，但我们确实非常努力。
I'll give us that because Carter and I were that whole summer, we were recording music my mom's basement while also writing like three portfolios, right?
我会告诉我们，因为卡特和我整个夏天都在我妈妈的地下室录制音乐，同时还写了三个作品集，对吧？
Like Conan, like Letterman, and like Letterman was like the least fleshed out on it.
就像柯南，就像莱特曼，而莱特曼就像是最不充实的人。
Well, there's just, it was the most exciting.
嗯，这就是最令人兴奋的。
I mean, we spent the whole year working on our Conan packet because it was like, it's got to be Conan, this Conan or nothing.
我的意思是，我们花了整整一年的时间来制作《柯南》数据包，因为它就像是，它必须是柯南，这个柯南或者什么都不是。
Yeah.
是的。
You loved Letterman.
你爱莱特曼。
I had not watched a lot of Letterman.
我没看过太多莱特曼。
I was like, I was not a Letterman guy necessarily.
我当时想，我不一定是莱特曼人。
But then like David Minor, who who maddened hooked us up with who gets, you know, he's, we have him to thank for our career, for sure.
但就像大卫·米诺一样，他让我们疯狂地与他联系在一起，你知道，他是我们的职业生涯，我们要感谢他，这是肯定的。
David Miner was like, he, uh, he basically gave us the news, like they're not hiring at Conan.
大卫·迈纳说，他，呃，他基本上给了我们这个消息，就像柯南不再招聘一样。
Everyone loves it there, obviously, because why would you ever quit this amazing fun show?
显然，每个人都喜欢那里，因为你为什么要退出这个精彩有趣的节目呢？
Uh, but two writers had just left Letterman and they were hiring and they're looking for people.
呃，但是两位作家刚刚离开莱特曼，他们正在招聘和寻找人才。
And it was, this is like on a Friday and it was like, can you get them a Letterman packet by Monday?
就像是在周五，你能在周一之前给他们寄来莱特曼包裹吗？
And we had a little bit of a start on it, but it was like maybe 20, 30% we just stayed up here.
我们有一点开始，但大概有 20%、30% 我们只是留在这里。
Each show needed a different packet, like tonally, because they were different.
每个节目都需要不同的数据包，比如音调，因为它们是不同的。
So a Conan has to be different than a letterman packet.
所以柯南必须与莱特曼的包裹不同。
Especially a letterman.
尤其是一个信使。
Because letterman is so like about his voice and about his like specific thing that he does.
因为莱特曼非常喜欢他的声音和他所做的具体事情。
You had 72 hours to write an enormous amount of comedic material in the voice and style of David Letterman.
你有 72 个小时的时间，用大卫·莱特曼的声音和风格写了大量的喜剧材料。
While living at my mother's house in Long Island.
住在长岛我母亲的家里时。
Yeah, and but it's funny.
是的，但这很有趣。
I've been graduated.
我已经毕业了。
Yeah, we were like, yeah, we would like go to a diner and like, like, thank, you know, and by the way, Jane Thomas, I owe her my life as well, because she'd like put me up for that summer.
是的，我们就像，是的，我们想去一家餐馆，就像，谢谢，你知道，顺便说一句，简·托马斯，我也欠她一条命，因为她愿意让我度过那个夏天。
Like I was like living in Craig's house.
就像我住在克雷格的房子里一样。
How can I met my mother?
我怎样才能见到我的妈妈？
But I just remember it's like the, there was a moment of that we had to push through, but a moment of like, we just spent nine months on this Conan O'Brien packet.
但我只记得，有那么一刻，我们必须坚持下去，但有那么一刻，我们只花了九个月的时间在这个柯南·奥布莱恩的包裹上。
And you're telling us we have to generate a top 10 list and we only have two days to do it.
您告诉我们必须生成前 10 名列表，而我们只有两天的时间来完成。
That's outrageous.
这太离谱了。
And like, you know, the joke being to write a top 10 list, you have like three hours to do it when you get the job.
就像，你知道，一个笑话是写一份前十名的清单，当你得到这份工作时，你有大约三个小时的时间来完成它。
Yeah, but yeah, that was a very long weekend, but ultimately a successful one.
是的，但是，是的，那是一个很长的周末，但最终是一个成功的周末。
So you get the packet into them by Monday.
所以你可以在周一之前把包裹寄给他们。
When do you hear that you're hired?
你什么时候听说你被录用了？
Like the next few days into that week, our lives change, our lives change, like what?
就像那周接下来的几天，我们的生活发生了变化，我们的生活发生了变化，就像什么？
Like maybe the next week after that, we started a Carter.
也许在那之后的下周，我们开始了卡特。
I was like, it was so fast.
我当时想，这太快了。
Yeah, we had like a, we did one interview with Tim Long, who was the head writer.
是的，我们对首席作家蒂姆·朗进行了一次采访。
And then shout out to Tim as well, shout out to Tim and Kate Adler who was the producer at the time and she she the two of them sort of bumped us up to the next and then the second interview was on the 12th floor Which I think we didn't we didn't understand the meaning of that at the time But in in the letterman days the 12th floor was Dave's floor like that's that's like the that's like the the main production floor of Letterman and we But it was with Rob Ernett, the executive producer at the time, and Rob, you know, we file in, we go up the elevator to this, and it's not a big, it's not like a labyrinth.
然后也向蒂姆大声喊叫，向当时的制片人蒂姆和凯特·阿德勒大声喊叫，他们两个把我们推到了下一个，然后第二次采访是在 12 楼，我想我们没有，我们当时不明白这意味着什么，但在莱特曼时代，12 楼是戴夫的楼层，就像那样，就像莱特曼和我们的主要制作楼层一样，但它是和当时的执行制片人 Rob Ernett 一起，还有 Rob，你知道，我们鱼贯而入，乘电梯到达这里，它并不大，也不像迷宫。
It's like an L-shape of the floor plan of the 12th floor, but we go in, and he's down at one end, and we go into Rob's office, and I remember Rob, this is how young we were, we had our resumes attached to the thing, and they were like, and Rob, I remember Rob being like, well, their grades are really good.
这就像 12 楼平面图的 L 形，但我们进去了，他在一端，我们进入罗布的办公室，我记得罗布，我们当时多么年轻，我们把简历贴在这个东西上，他们就像，罗布，我记得罗布说，嗯，他们的成绩真的很好。
We had a GPA.
我们有平均绩点（GPA）。
They're like, good GPAs.
他们的平均绩点（GPA）很好。
So, uh, but yeah, in that moment, he was like, this is on the month of October.
所以，呃，但是，是的，在那一刻，他就像，现在是十月。
Yeah.
是的。
Not bad.
不错。
I know CPR.
我知道心肺复苏术。
I'm interested in that.
我对此很感兴趣。
I don't know CPR.
我不懂心肺复苏术。
Um, but, uh, but that was on a Friday.
嗯，但是，呃，但是那是在星期五。
And he basically said, like, ah, they seemed good to me.
他基本上是说，啊，它们对我来说似乎很好。
And then he turned to us and it was like, uh, enjoy this weekend.
然后他转向我们，就像是，呃，享受这个周末。
This is as good as this job is going to get because starting Monday, it's going to be terrible.
这已经是这份工作所能得到的最好的结果了，因为从周一开始，一切都会变得很糟糕。
But, uh, you know, coming on Monday and you're hired.
但是，呃，你知道，周一来你就被录用了。
And we walked out and we're so stunned that we got lost in the complex L shape floor plan of the toes and no way to get lost, but we got lost all the way down the hall.
我们走出去，惊呆了，我们在脚趾复杂的L形平面图中迷路了，没有办法迷路，但我们沿着走廊一路迷路。
We turned the only corner, we turned the corner, the only corner of the whole hallway.
我们拐过唯一的拐角，我们拐过拐角，整个走廊唯一的拐角。
And we turn the corner and like you can film this in your mind, it's it's high noon.
我们转过拐角，就像你可以在脑海中拍摄这一幕一样，现在是正午。
And there are the other end is David Letterman, like standing alone, like I think he was like tossing a football, just standing there.
另一端是大卫·莱特曼，就像独自站着一样，我认为他就像扔一个足球一样，只是站在那里。
like he's maybe going to kick our ass or something, and we say to him, do you know where the elevator is?
就像他可能会踢我们的屁股什么的，我们对他说，你知道电梯在哪里吗？
And he says, it doesn't fall.
他说，它不会掉落。
And like I love, I remember that particular phrasing, do you know where the elevator is?
就像我喜欢的那样，我记得那个特定的措辞，你知道电梯在哪里吗？
Like this building that has your name on it in giant lights?
喜欢这座用巨型灯光刻有您名字的建筑吗？
Wow.
哇。
You do it the other way.
你用另一种方式来做。
That's an incredibly charming story.
这是一个极其迷人的故事。
I love that you guys read in him and this mythic kind of character.
我喜欢你们读到他和这个神话般的人物。
Yeah.
是的。
And I think we were wearing backpacks.
我想我们都背着背包。
I think we brought backpacks in the meaning.
我想我们带背包就是这个意思。
He called us the backpack boys behind our back for years.
多年来他在背后称我们为背包男孩。
Yeah, the backpack was our nickname, the worst boy, the worst boy man of all time, the, the rough draft is the most be boys and the most be boys, so you guys are there.
是的，背包是我们的昵称，最糟糕的男孩，有史以来最糟糕的男孩，粗略的选秀是最男孩和最男孩，所以你们都在那里。
How long?
多长时间？
Six years.
六年了。
Four and a half years.
四年半了。
Oh, four and a half.
哦，四岁半。
Four and a half.
四点半。
Okay.
好的。
The next time we talk today, after that story was just when we said goodbye, we probably talked about three other times in between.
今天我们下次聊的时候，在那个故事之后，就在我们告别的时候，我们中间可能还聊了另外三个话题。
Tell me, what did you guys learn at Letterman that helped you write and run how I met your mother?
告诉我，你们在莱特曼学到了什么来帮助你们编写和运行《我如何遇见你们母亲》？
Everything, right, Carter?
一切，对吧，卡特？
Like, everything.
就像，一切。
After Letterman, we were on a couple of other sitcoms that are sort of forgettable, didn't really go the distance.
在《莱特曼》之后，我们还出演了其他几部情景喜剧，这些情景喜剧有点令人忘记，并没有真正走下去。
Although we're an American dad, which is still on TV, which is amazing.
虽然我们是一个美国爸爸，但这仍然在电视上，这太棒了。
We're in there for one season.
我们在那里呆了一个赛季。
But basically, everything we needed to learn to be a showrunner, we learned at Letterman.
但基本上，我们在莱特曼学到了成为一名制片人所需的一切。
And then when you go on to a sitcom staff, a lot of the ethos at least back in the day when we were getting into it was like the writers weren't in the edit room.
然后当你继续接触情景喜剧的工作人员时，至少在我们进入它的那天，很多精神就像编剧不在编辑室一样。
The writers weren't necessarily always on set.
编剧不一定总是在片场。
The writers sort of wrote things and were that part of the assembly line.
作家们写了一些东西，并且是流水线的一部分。
On Letterman, you had, if you had an idea in the morning, you had to produce it by the showtime.
在莱特曼身上，如果你早上有一个想法，你就必须在放映前将其付诸实践。
You had to get your music.
你必须得到你的音乐。
You had to order up your graphics.
你必须订购你的图形。
You had to, if there was like Kiron and like titles involved, you had every piece of it.
你必须这么做，如果有像《Kiron》之类的游戏，你就拥有了它的每一个部分。
You went on the shoot.
你去拍摄了。
You basically kind of directed or co-directed your bit.
你基本上是导演或共同导演你的部分。
you had with the director and make sure you got everything you needed, get into an edit room, book your time there, get with the editor, like every part of it was you, every part of it you were responsible for producing.
你和导演在一起，确保你得到了你需要的一切，进入剪辑室，在那里预订时间，和剪辑师在一起，就像它的每个部分都是你，你负责制作它的每个部分一样。
And that was such good training for being a showrunner because by the time, I think by the time some writers who've only ever been on sitcom staffs, they become a showrunner, they've never really spent a lot of time in edit, they've never done a sound mix, they've never, we had done all that stuff.
这对成为一名剧集主管来说是很好的培训，因为到了那个时候，我认为当一些只在情景喜剧工作人员中工作过的作家成为一名剧集主管时，他们从来没有真正花很多时间在编辑上，他们从来没有做过混音，他们从来没有，我们已经做了所有这些事情。
It can't be overstated how much like technology and like the editing software that exists in a like eye movie coming built into your laptop.
无论如何强调，它与笔记本电脑内置的类似眼睛电影中的技术和编辑软件有多么相似。
How much that has changed the world because at the time it really was like us knowing how to go into an edit room was like like we'd gone to Hogwarts.
这对世界产生了多大的改变，因为当时我们真的知道如何进入编辑室就像我们去了霍格沃茨一样。
Like we like had this like mystical power that like like really like no one understood how to like you know trim 15 frames off of something like like dumb simple stuff that anyone in the world now knows.
就像我们喜欢拥有这种神秘的力量，就像真的没有人知道如何像你知道的那样，从世界上任何人现在都知道的愚蠢简单的东西中剪掉 15 帧。
It was really that letterman definitely gave us a chance to basically go to film school for four years.
确实莱特曼确实给了我们一个基本上去电影学校读四年的机会。
It was film school and comedy school in a big way.
从很大程度上来说，这是电影学校和喜剧学校。
I also feel like the whole 10,000 hours thing of learning how to, I definitely feel like I learned how to write a joke and how to write something that gets a laugh.
我也觉得在学习如何写一万个小时的过程中，我确实觉得我学会了如何写一个笑话以及如何写一些让人发笑的东西。
I don't even think that myself is necessarily a funny person, but I knew what the mechanics were of had, and the only way to learn that is doing it over and over and failing a lot.
我什至不认为自己一定是一个有趣的人，但我知道其中的机制是什么，而学习这一点的唯一方法就是一遍又一遍地做，并多次失败。
And like, yeah, I wanted to ask you about the failure.
就像，是的，我想问你关于失败的事情。
Did it, it did it, thicken your skin considerably.
做到了，做到了，让你的脸皮显着变厚。
So you, you pitch jokes, obviously, to these older, more veteran writers, and they're swatting them down or ideas are getting, you know, batted down or something doesn't get a laugh.
所以，你，显然，你向这些年长、更有经验的作家讲笑话，他们正在猛烈地抨击这些笑话，或者你知道，你的想法受到了打击，或者有些东西没有得到笑声。
Like, did you feel like that, which didn't kill you made you stronger kind of by the end of that?
就像，你有没有这样的感觉，这并没有杀死你，但到最后却让你变得更坚强？
Yeah, definitely.
是的，绝对是。
And it was very humbling and it told you it was a volume business.
这是非常令人谦卑的，它告诉你这是一项批量业务。
You needed to have an extra joke.
你需要一个额外的笑话。
You needed to have an extra idea.
你需要有一个额外的想法。
There was no, there's no writers block when you're doing five shows a week and you're getting paid decent money to do it.
不，当你每周做五场演出并且你得到了可观的报酬时，就没有作家的障碍。
There's no writer.
没有作家。
You have to have an idea.
你必须有一个想法。
And even if it's not great, you have to do, you have to produce it and make it and hope that it gets on and does okay.
即使它不是很好，你也必须这样做，你必须生产它并制作它，并希望它能够顺利进行并表现良好。
Carter and I did the viewer mail segment for four years of our four and a half years there.
卡特和我在那里工作了四年半，其中四年半都在做观众邮件部分。
And you, we would go down for the taping of that segment and be in the audience.
而你，我们会去录制该片段并成为观众。
And you had to sit in that audience and we stood up to the side and we would sit there and listen to those played and either get a laugh from the audience or not get a laugh from the audience and what didn't get a laugh and it was dead silent and Dave's up there.
你必须坐在观众席上，我们站在一边，我们会坐在那里听那些演奏的音乐，要么让观众笑，要么不让观众笑，如果没有笑，那就是一片死寂，而戴夫就在那里。
This iconic, wonderful, I mean, I idolized Dave, I love him, I made that joke before, but I love Dave.
这个标志性的，美妙的，我的意思是，我崇拜戴夫，我爱他，我以前开过那个玩笑，但我爱戴夫。
When he would turn on it, he'd go like, oh, that was a tough one, Paul.
当他打开它时，他会说，哦，这很难，保罗。
I feel like we're getting torn a new one on national television by our hero or at least my hero.
我觉得我们的英雄，或者至少是我的英雄，正在国家电视台上撕扯一场新的戏。
And there's nothing more humbling.
没有什么比这更令人谦卑的了。
There's no thicker skin to be developed than that moment.
没有比那一刻更厚的脸皮了。
And you got to scrape yourself off the floor and say, I got at least one more shot at this next week if we don't get fired.
你必须把自己从地板上爬起来，说，如果我们不被解雇的话，下周我至少还有一次机会。
And you just work even harder.
而你只是更加努力地工作。
And you develop that ability to bounce back.
你就会培养出反弹的能力。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任监制。
The show was produced by me, Alec Webb, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Webb 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios, artwork by John Marrow.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves，作品由 John Marrow 设计。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliott Connards.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《NYC》，特别感谢 Lola Kennedy 和 Elliott Connards。
Visit howwemajormother.com to sign up for our sub-stack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 howwemajormother.com 注册我们的子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Riders' newsletters on Substack, read Craig Thomas' published prose at CraigThomasRider.com, and you can subscribe to my Dead Fathers Society also on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Riders 的时事通讯，阅读 Craig Thomas 在 CraigThomasRider.com 上发表的散文，您还可以在 Substack 上订阅我的《死亡父亲协会》。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for a congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这展示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of backyard ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
这一集是在 Backyard Ventures 的支持和 Tink Media 的营销支持下得以实现的。
But will, in fact, dance.
但事实上，他会跳舞。